bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono paris jackson dati sul gioco
dell'anno dell'anno 2010 che è più
iniziamo a puntata 185 quindi oggi un po
special come sempre ogni cinque puntate
facciamo uno special
vediamo se riesco a fare un livello
abbastanza decente parti il battitore di
macchine che italiano incredibile che
ciò ecco salve smetti di qua pezzente
schifo ajax come faccio a prenderlo
aspetta 722 danni aspetta porco demonio
madonna spedizione la produzione tutta
qui stare fermo un attimo
l'ho preso aspettano così e vabbè
[Musica]
medio di un film di 007 comunque rock
swing king free hanno fatto addirittura
il 3 pensate come fatto bene suo livello
beh la partenza è stata giusta
il che è incredibile perché sono andata
donna che botta sono andato di
intuizione igiene l'ambientazione non è
mai il massimo soprattutto niger
soprattutto happy with però
evidentemente oggi c'è qualcosa in più
non so che cosa let's golf 3 no è
difficile o avevi chiamerà arrivato ma
dai era fortissimo sbagliato alla fine
farc amaca per una volta potevo fare una
bella figura a posto porca vacca che è
successo salve piano sto un po airc c'è
un cervo morto quelle sono mosche in hd
sono perso nella foresta del cocer
buonasera mi spiegate cosa è successo
qua dentro che non ho capi c'è anche il
nonno ciak mezzo martoriato sul tavolo
scusate ma cosa è successo qui mi scusi
mi fai passare un attimo per favore che
è porca vacca aiuto ho sporcato la in
tutto sto casino non sono riuscita ad
uscire di casa devo smontare i mobili
che siamo all'ikea
occhio che c'è un ascia che perfetto era
rimasta lì a pendolo e ragazzi potete
evitare di fare queste cose mentre sto
girando la foresta proprio adesso avete
fatto casino
salve c'è uno che nell'ombra
va bene chi è stato è stato lei a questo
casino qua mi spiega qual è il problema
tanto mi sono infilato in un carrello
mai jason è sceso un livello di 13 però
lo trovo un po ingrassato rispetto al
socio era era così prima adesso non so
se niente c'è solo un jason qualcuno ha
urlato fa niente non ci giriamo
continuiamo sono caduto sono morto morto
sono morto aiuto ma dove è quello che ha
lanciato lascia tipo era qua
l'attenzione che poi devo fare il tifo
una schiva mamma mia
però non lo posso sapere io dove la
gente no stai fermo qualche aiuto allora
è successo niente cosa che attivato ma
cosa attivato a quello e non l'avevo
mica visto appena scienza tra tutti gli
ascensori potranno capitarmi uno così
gambero che grazie e dove dovrei andare
di preciso dovevo salirla sopra non ci
sono salito a baida ci siamo ragazzi
sono rifatta teoricamente se prendo la
rincorsa ci arrivo perfetto però non le
dico lo steccone
[Musica]
c'è sono stato due ore per rifare il
livello per poi arrivare lì ed era
finito era finito male tips siamo su un
altro pianeta spiega mi di mi ricordo
don't look zio fighissimo la mia testa
fa male skipass è proprio la cinematica
ma dove sono i miei compagni è meglio
che vada a cercare fuori ma come è
possibile
bellissimo hanno fatto la cinematica sua
happy with aprite la torta o buonissimo
ma siamo su un pianeta contro avete
sconosciuto day one
per questo tizio in rush varie ok vado
vado di corsa
non ho capito cosa devo fare però non
per niente nuova t che schifo facciata
spider i gerarchi fuori spray c'è un
ragno che sta cercando la sua preda con
dio tantissimo che schifo togliti
togliti fai schifo
vai via madonna non ha preso dunque che
dovrà non staccarmi lo staccati a devo
prendere le palle non si può fare
spaccare il culo a raich cosa faccio mi
fa veramente schifo questo appare meglio
se lo lasciamo lì dove devo andare
raga non ho capito cosa devo fare vi
giuro non si apre sta roba il cosa non
lo posso battere e magnani non possono
anche farli mangiare come voi neanche
magnate ha finalmente a posto era sesto
livello allora era così facile
preistorico vyrus un livello chiamato
salve chiamato così
ma perché ho un fucile a pompa in mano
come lo uso per a falde buongiorno a lei
cosa devo fare keep out don't look split
solo di ragazzi scusate ma dove sta
andando
presentato a dentro varcare la porta a
porta non si spacca perché sento questo
rumore di continuo che è successo
devo andare credo fa o si è aperto un
passaggio segreto dovessero andare ma
dove sto andando ma cos'è ma poi tra
l'altro su una scala cosa succede nelle
fogne che schifo escrementi dove stiamo
andando ragazzi ma allora preistoriche
vyrus porca vacca si va beh quello è
quello è un cavaliere nel medio senti
evidente di morire
meno male che è cascato da sotto che
sono ero praticamente morto perché stavo
andando veramente l'edito salve no no
io non sto capendo una sega di quello
che sto vedendo però che piace è fatto
veramente bene il suo livello otranto
finito l'arma non ce l'ho più perché non
ha cibo un'altra ala è la madonna
state calmi ma che è successo
roba da un calma è tanto non sono mica
uno che è sbucato dal pavimento
lo sai che è tutto un tuo fallimento
questo dicevo io a tuo padre è infetto
chiudere a sto provando a proporre fino
a questo virus e provaci tira una leva
il modo giusto e tirando una leva hanno
forse deve attivare io questo ho
attivato un coso gigante che non so cosa
significa ci sono dentro mi sono
sacrificato per l'umanità cosa è
successo
il ragazzi non sto capendo una sequenza
succede come uccido non reggano nostro
caffè avevi io ho fatto male a sei quasi
morto 20 eccolo l'ho ucciso sono forte
ma adesso
cosa sta succedendo
datemi una spiegazione perché vi giuro
non capisco nicchia soprassalto
allucinante qua e là che è successo
[Musica]
io non ho io
un alt facciamo un altro ragazzo tutto
sto casino se le tesi più level
difficulty ma cosa vuoi dai dai
ma con chi penserà che fai giocare
questa 26 anni penso che non sia in
grado ko 3 2 1 giallorosso barca vacca
con chi pensi avere a che fare
lui lo schifoso beh gioco è più vista un
sacco di anni ma potrei sempre
migliorare mi stava causando lui cosa
devo fermarmi primari è stato bravo a
fermarsi quindi per un cimento
ok senso di schifo
dove vai vieni qua notizia è veramente
difficile giocare a mario kart e non tra
le banane
oddio picchi è diventato ci ho mentito e
vabbè non mi sono salvato lusso come che
culo superano bravissimo però dai
ragazzi c'era un buco
comunque non è quello che veramente
hanno fatto una provata a un certo punto
e sono uscito a morire in modo più
stupido c'è il modo più difficile c'è il
modo più facile per morire non sono
morto ma solo porto nel modo più stupido
era un genio
andrete un genio che adesso non sono
ancora in gara e ragazzo ma per i gara
ha mai pregato stava andando meglio
prima effettivamente prova niente cielo
ei edizione questa fase al contrario
vita è difficilissimo perché non le
vedono le gambe non avendo le gambe non
riesco a fare sono morto ormai ragazzi
diventata solo una questione personale
devo battere lui cioè non è neanche ma
neanche guarda l'importante arrivare
alla fine del livello
l'ultima in difficile ragazzi l'ultima
in difficile
l'ultimo tentativo sono ministero
sconfitto allegramente da sto tizio è
veramente impulsi propriamente lui lo
faccio in difficile perché me la sento
ma è l'ultima veramente l'ultimo
tentativo poi tante lo devo anche fare
in modo di vincere non è solo arrivare
al finale capito di vincerla cioè se non
ci fosse lui sarebbe comunque un livelli
impossibili più c'è anche lui che deve
battere sul tempo è possibile sarò
mentre o limonato il mio mezzo di
locomozione
concludo il video spero ragazzi io vi
sia piaciuto è stata veramente difficile
sta gara ma nel prossimo speciale
proverò a partire esattamente con questo
livello e vedere se
può farlo il giorno ormai l'ho presa sul
personale giuro come al solito ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al
canale e sono stato sconfitto sua happy
meals non so come dirlo a mia madre
[Musica]